[Music]
i know a lot of you are headed back to
school but if you playstation plus
subscribers want to skip
class and play video games like i did
then i've got you covered with
september's batch of games
just don't forget to hit that subscribe
button to be the first to know about the
ps plus lineup every month
oh and don't actually skip class
first up ps4 players are getting
infamous second son
despite the name it's actually the third
game in the series putting you in the
shoes of delson rowe whose powers let
him manipulate
smoke neon and other wild materials
note that this does not include the
standalone expansion first light
but the ps4 lineup does include another
action-packed game
strike vector ex is an aerial combat
game that brings to mind other high
altitude shooters like crimson skies
strike vector has a single player mode
but the main course here is in
multiplayer modes like deathmatch
demolition and capture the flag
on top of that the playstation vr
exclusive rigs will be free to ps plus
members from september 5th
all the way to november 7th if you've
never played the competitive mech combat
game before you've got plenty of time to
try it out
ps3 players also get a pair of titles
the first being a game called truck
racer in which
you guessed it you race trucks it
features 10 different environments with
48 tracks in all
and if you want to play the world's most
beautiful sport then you'll be pretty
lucky to have a ps3 next month
that's right handball 16 is the second
free ps plus game on the platform
wait you thought i was talking about
what sport the first vita game for
september is we are doomed a twin stick
shooter that has you zapping enemies in
a variety of different modes like waves
and endless
oh and it's from the developer behind
graceful explosion machine so you get to
see what that team was up to last year
and the second free vita game is had a
full boyfriend but i need to ask you a
question
do you like pigeons i mean like
like pigeons well then hatful boyfriend
is the game for you
it's a dating simulator that puts you in
the shoes of a new human student at an
all bird school
and best of all both free vita games are
playable on ps4
and those are your free ps plus games
for september they go live on the 5th
and remember you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles
over at gamespot that's where we've also
written up the european lineup which
includes the platformer rpg
child of lights
you